after a year in which oil prices
dominated the news you might think the
same issues will Drive next year's
energy stories but if you just focus on
oil prices you'll miss the larger
picture for 2016 we rely on oil of
course for transportation and
petrochemicals but it's not the only
game in town anymore as our reliance on
oil shrinks will turn not just one new
source of energy but several this is
different than what's happened in the
past previously one form of energy was
superseded by another in 19th century
our reliance on wood gave way to coal
and in the 20th century that yielded to
oil but in the 21st century the next
step won't be an orderly progression
from one fuel to the next it'll be a
free fall so which source stands the
best shop let's get the easy answer out
of the way first it isn't going to be
cold although Japan and China will add
coal plants this year coal share of US
electricity production has gone down 17%
since 2005 coal is just too dirty in the
face of climate change nuclear energy
isn't doing so hot these days either
since Fukushima several aging US plants
have been closed and Germany Japan
Taiwan and other countries are planning
to phase out nuclear energy altogether
from there though the energy picture
gets a lot sunnier natural gas is the
big success story of the past few years
pouring out of u.s. fracking projects
and undercutting coal as a cheap source
of electricity
wind power is as cheap as coal in
Germany in the UK and demand for solar
is actually the highest it's ever been
which may have something to do with the
price of solar panels tooth rubbing 95%
since 2008 in spite of all this upheaval
oil is still king
it's our single largest power source and
that's not going to change in 2016
between high u.s. output Iran probably
resuming its exports and Saudi Arabia
low-balling to maintain market share oil
prices are likely to stay low for a
while which means less incentive to find
an alternative but there's a funny thing
about oil you may not have noticed it
doesn't really compete with the others
directly oil mostly powers cars ships
and planes while the others mostly
generate electricity the wild card for
oil in 2016 and Beyond is how fast cars
might start to run on electricity
instead of gasoline or diesel even when
we see a big shift it may signal the
true end of the oil age but it won't be
replaced by the solar age or the biofuel
age or the wind age it will be replaced
by all